oh yeah mario time and yes the wii u is
here at PAX Prime I got to play it one
of the first things i played was new
super mario brothers you because it's a
mario game and the funny thing is he
can't really just proved that up what's
the lever you play it with the wiimote
just like you do new super mario
brothers so that's all the same the big
thing that's different is he use the wii
u controller and if you're using that
you don't even play the game but that
person gets to draw blocks on the game
and create platforms for people to jump
on now if you play new super mario
brothers you know that when you play it
with about four people there's no way
for the game to go other than completely
chaotic and absolutely absurd zzzz but
you create these blocks you want to help
people you want to make platforms what
ends up happening is you end up killing
the people you book platforms there and
then they put them above their head
accidentally and they hit it and they
die so what will happen is you want to
be a hero you want to have a hero
complex you want to save everybody what
you'll end up doing is actually killing
them so you're going to do what's
actually easy and you're going to create
platforms to actually purposely kill
people because you just want to fall
into your own and be that person because
you want to be successful at what you do
and if what you do is kill people well
you're going to do it on purpose that
being said it's going to be a really fun
thing to do so hey that's the role that
I'm going to play in New Super Mario
Brothers you I'm just saying and another
game I played for the Wii U is zombie
you know zombie you is fun it's absurdly
hard I mean first of all zombies are
going to beat the living piss out of you
in this game there's no escaping that
it's about as logical as me doing a
zombie you video in the same video as
Super Mario Brothers but again that's
how we roll here but zombie you it's a
fun enough zombie game know that zombie
games are a dime a dozen out that there
are so many of them that zombie you has
to stand out it uses the wii u gimmick
in sense that when you open your menu
screen you look down on the wii u screen
that's how you scroll through your menus
the game doesn't stop the zombies can
still tear your head off while you're
looking through the menu and that's kind
of the gimmick of it and other than that
you get little devices that you're
looking through the wii u controller
that's like looking through the device
in the game however i don't think it's
enough it just seems a little gimmicky
all i want is hardcore just solid
gameplay you know like super mario
brothers barely uses the wii u
controller solid game i love it you know
that first wave of wii games and that
first wave of wii games all use the weed
gimmick it was supposed to be all great
and ultimately everyone walked away from
the games going it's a bit gimmicky so
that's I feel like this is what this is
like but we use here glad it's here I
feel like it has potential but right now
all the games here are launched idle
games that are a bit gimmicky so we need
the year two games here that's what we
need so next year I'll put you in and
how that's going other than that zombiu
fun frustrating difficult and enjoyable
enough zombie game it's not as good as
left for dead that's my opinion I could
be wrong but that's just me and I'm
uploading a lot of tax videos and the
way YouTube structured if I upload click
more than one video in the day it's
going to get buried so I have a few
packs videos out there so be sure to
check those out tues this isn't the only
one I've uploaded I think this is
probably number five or something so be
sure to check those out people are
driving about the punch I'll actually
punch it